la presa de rioski ha sido reventada y
sus orillas están minadas son los restos
de los combates entre la región de
harqui y el donbas olec es un pescador y
geólogo que vive en la zona desde el
inicio de la invasión ha visto como el
lugar en el Que Pesca Desde niño se
convirtió en un sitio estratégico para
los dos ejércitos enfrentados
los ríos son vida Aquí la gente siempre
ha vivido cerca pero en el comienzo de
la guerra esta naturaleza también nos
ayudó el río nos ayudó
Ucrania es uno de los países europeos
con la mayor proporción de aguas
continentales junto con los países
escandinavos y vela rusa a tan sólo 50
kilómetros de aquí el río oscila sede
Barrera natural a una zona bajo control
Ruso y otra en la que están las tropas
ucranianas cruzar los ríos sigue siendo
según los expertos militares un reto en
las ofensivas y contraofensivas en
Ucrania los canales fluviales pueden
complicar el paso de mecanizados y
acorazados cuando los puentes son
destruidos
maxime cuenta como el río que atraviesa
y suma el donex frenó El Avance de las
tropas rusas en los primeros meses de la
invasión no pudieron atravesarlo
rápidamente para asediar a los
batallones ucranianos en el donbas
si hubieran podido cruzar rápidamente el
río entonces habrían podido rodear
nuestras tropas en las labianas y la
historia habría sido completamente
diferente
Pero el precio que se está pagando
también es alto en el óxil un número
desproporcionado de peces han aparecido
en zonas donde no había en el donex un
río que alimenta también el donbas
restos de morteros y proyectiles yacen
en sus aguas sin que nadie sepa cuando
se limpiarán